sacrament a punchline can't wait
good you invite your boys the great
clubs some of the best clubs in
literally some of the best combination
boys from what uh Sacramento do your big
dears Bros fan are they up there they're
there in Stockton which is right up
there you know I [ __ ] with the Diaz but
I was that that might I [ __ ] with them
hard
you rat that fight dude you were the
thought in the back
nah dude I see I know I see like this
rap homie back homie I'm off [ __ ] you
know what I realize I was like why is
rap acting like yeah they're like you
sure I had my hair dyed you know you
know what I realized about about being
that close to two to two fighters that I
love Derrick Lewis cuz I know him well
and kind of you know but like once you
for me for fighters you meet him you
know you you just have like you want to
see the wing of course so you just have
and he's such a lovable guy right the
best so so when he like I blacked out
when that dude had his arm I blacked out
around it like I was literally like it
was like rocky to to me like I was like
like like people am I sitting next I
mean I was sitting next to my man style
bender is he is he my bullet yeah yeah
he did your show I wouldn't say you guys
ever have a meal we had a meal okay
bring on the show and outside the show
okay all right well the thing is is I I
blacked the [ __ ] out but between him and
and Diaz like I was like yell it's like
when you you know a mom just cuz of
different I want them to win like I
wanted them to win and I [ __ ] with Jorge
it's hard like that fight was like you
have to like both of them I don't have
you met Jorge never met Jorge
but Nate's my guy I never met Nate if
you met Jorge yeah man they never made
me never met nice so new ones your guy
you're a fan I'm a fan I'm a fan well
don't say my god well Derek's my guy cuz
I know him
have you had a meal with him yes no no
meal but I just a super Phil I'm a real
fan yeah your fan I'm not a super fan
I'm at a super because I don't know all
the [ __ ] but they're the one dude the
Magna dude that what's in Colby Colby
um it was he interesting before he put
the people know him before he put on
that hat who's he fighting next
kymaro's Minh for the title and it was
the thing about Colby so it's on that
before he's about to get cut from the
asleep before he was like [ __ ] man I
need finish things out came up with this
huge gimmick and now you know I'm right
because of that Idol and he's like the
bad guy but the mag a bad guy he it's W
do he wants to go w w after this who's
gonna win life you meet Colby like I had
Kobe on the show on this show yes I know
are they my food truck I don't bring
fighters on the show food fight
franchise - [ __ ] them but no but food
truck is all fighters who trucks are
just fighting that's where I do just MMA
content but with Colby if you met him
he'd be your guy phenomenal guy great I
can't rock with you a few so for that
mmm I'm Tony it's such a it's such an
act for him like Ric Flair yeah hip to
him it's like WWE he's I can't what why
not you okay okay I don't know what what
else would I do
you got you I got you um you would love
them okay
but I [ __ ] with Nate III do you know
like with Nate and Nick the [ __ ] D
has a trouser does the [ __ ] D I
also want to say at the old studio and
by the way why do you guys keep changing
students you running from bill no
collectors know every time I come here a
new [ __ ] studio knit money bill
collectors money women may buy meat or
owing hit make and then notice how it's
an upgrade every single thing this is an
upgrade the last three ones there's like
oh we're running from the bilko this
one's an upgrade this is nice
wheeled the building yeah so here this
red we shoot three show all in the
building we run the buildings right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]